[Music]
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum hi ryan hello
again
thank you for wearing a mask and an
inside i'm just trying to do ads for you
just
um i'm just a billboard now
that's that's what this is dude i'll
tell you what it just it it relieves a
lot of stress because when you're not
here you know and people who listen it's
just like you know i gotta
make sure that's in focus the other
camera's in focus i gotta make sure this
is recording
and while i'm talking to someone i'm
like they're going what are you doing
i'm like i'm looking to see if it's
recording
and it stopped once on grant gustin um
so it happens and i understand it but it
was like it's just good to have you here
and you're kind of uh
taking care of business yeah i'm here
watching it all guys i want to say thank
you to everybody that's listening um
got some great news i can't mention it
right now uh
what a [ __ ] uh but it's great man
it's really good for the podcast i think
um i'm excited about it
um so it's coming and i want to thank
all you listeners out there um if you're
listening and you're not subscribed
please subscribe it helps the show so
much
write a review uh follow us on twitter
and instagram at inside of you podcast
on
instagram insightyoupod on twitter
follow me
at the michael rosenbaum um
it really helps the show and my patrons
out there uh hi guys
hey how are you that's ryan ryan's here
they love ryan
they love ryan um you guys have really
uh kept the show to kept the show afloat
and
um i i say this all the time to say it
on the patreon account
uh patreon's awesome what it is if you
don't know what patreon is it's uh
it's pretty much if you want to support
the podcast extra and get extra goodies
and
there's merch that i send and there's uh
inside of me where they get to ask me
questions and i create characters to ask
me the questions like i think i'm in
drag this week
uh just and it's a lot of fun and we do
these private youtube lives where i play
music and they have a dedicated
they have a request list uh request
what's a request line
yeah and uh it's just it's a great
community people are becoming friends so
you can go to
uh patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n and the other
one is um
it's very uh fitting for today's episode
uh the other
uh patreon is called where have all the
good horror movies gone we just started
don't have a lot of people on it yet but
john heater napoleon dynamite and i
we uh we talk horror movies and we have
all the good horror movies gone and we
do a review and people come on zoom with
us and we talk and it's horror and fun
and so uh join that one if you want um
and support uh support that but i just
want to say thank you again for
supporting the show
and ryan for always delivering great
episodes seriously uh i couldn't do this
without you um
this week uh july 30th in
forma i'm doing a virtual con so you can
get zooms with me you can get zooms with
me and tom welling superman
you can zoom with both of us we do a q a
is
uh it's gonna be a lot of fun that's
july 30th and uh thank you everybody for
uh uh tipping and watching and
enjoying and winning prizes for the
rosenbaum and dancing show
we did on stage it and we just performed
this last weekend and it went
awesome and we did a bunch of zooms and
uh
so we'll be doing more every month we're
gonna do a stage at rosenbaum and dance
and we haven't figured out a freaking
name so if you can come up with a name
for two guys who need a name for a band
dance of the roses he does he doesn't
like that i said dancing roses
the dancing roses dancing roses yeah and
then he was just like
no it's stupid and he's like shut up
anyway let's get into it afterwards uh
we'll talk more and uh
all that stuff but this is a good friend
of mine for many years he got really
famous directing cabin fever
and uh hostile movies and um
uh so so many movies i mean he's he just
knock knock with keanu reeves he um he
was
bare jew on glorious bastards he's
constantly working
he's constantly working on himself which
i love which you'll hear
and it's nice and i at the end i would i
really hadn't
i didn't prepare myself that much i
don't
not that i prepare so much anyway
because i just like to talk and get
inside and it just
it was it was it felt good ryan liked it
a lot
that proved you proved all right let's
get inside elaire off it's my point of
view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
so look i haven't talked to you know in
a while we kind of keep in touch where
it's like a text like seeing how each
other are doing
i know you're crazy i know you're busy i
mean are you
i mean you're one of those minds that
always you're doing so many things if
you go to imdb
pro or imdb depending
you look at this and it's like the list
i'm like holy [ __ ] in development
this guy's got this guy will be working
till he's a hundred i don't know if
that's
well yeah i don't i don't know if it's
good or bad but i do have a weird
i've talked this is something i thought
a lot about
you know if the lockdown went another
six months i would just be
writing and writing and writing it's
been uh
my brain i always have like 50 things i
want to do but you're the same way you
want a podcast you want to play music
you want to act you want to produce you
want to write like
we we just we're also from a generation
where you can do anything you just have
to push yourself
you know we weren't told you can only be
one thing we
we were from that wave of okay you can
start
directing your own shows you know if
you're on a show you're going to start
directing them and you're going to start
producing them you're going to start so
i always
i was also like no one's going to let me
in i better
just keep i better have so many ideas
that i'm doing as a writer producer
director that way one of them will go
you know because if you put all your
eggs into one basket
what happened on hostile too and then
the week before it comes out it leaks on
the internet and you're like
leaked on the internet it was all over
people were buying those dvds weren't
they on in mexico and
brazil for a penny everything yeah it
got leaked and i know how it got leaked
it was a huge bummer and it still did
well but it was like oh i just spent a
year of my life on this thing and now
it's just
gone just out there for free so that was
a big wake-up call like
okay i want to have you know start doing
diversify like doing television shows
producing movies
having stuff that can always kind of
keep going and now i've
you know i want to write books i want to
do animation i want to do kid stuff
i want to do more horror i want to do
producing so you just kind of
i find that sometimes if i'm overdoing
it
i'm doing it to like distract myself
from dealing with whatever reality i'm
not
facing um and so i really have to filter
if this was the last thing i would say
like if i died tomorrow and this was the
last thing i did
would i be proud of it you know and
stuff like history of horror
for sure falls in that category like
every episode of that show
i'm so excited even though it's not a
big money maker i'm just so
excited to just talk about horror movies
and interview people and then
other movies like borderlands the thing
i'm doing for lionsgate
it's like a giant it's so many pieces
it's like mobilizing an
army and coronavirus has just made
everyone confused and a little bit
unsure of how to proceed so they're sort
of stumbling a little and then holding
back like okay we're going to shoot here
wait a minute the virus is spiked
we can shoot there oh wait i don't know
if we can if if like there's going to be
enough available crew
now there's the scramble for the three
or four safe countries where you can
shoot um
you know which is like australia germany
new zealand so it's it's just a weird
time go back for a second the my
question is i'm going to rewind a few
minutes
and you said you know and you start and
then you start wondering am i keeping
busy just
am i doing these things just to uh uh uh
not not move yourself yeah not deal with
yourself that
just rang true to me i i talked to my
psychiatrist this morning
and uh you know i was telling them that
i'm doing all these things and i think
you know
and i think a lot of people they just
keep as busy as they can so they don't
have to deal with their inner [ __ ]
and i wonder if how healthy is it
to just keep being busy and not dealing
with [ __ ]
or always dealing with [ __ ] i talk about
this in therapy a lot too that
you know you know enthusiasm comes and
goes
but inspiration you gotta go after it
with a club like you just gotta
and i read stephen king's book on
writing where he talks about
he's like the little muse is there in
the house you just gotta knock and let
him know you're home
and i always try to write five pages a
day that's my thing
even if i don't know what's gonna happen
and i'm like i put it off and
when you sit down and you just start
doing it sometimes it comes out in 45
minutes sometimes it's four hours
and a lot of the times i get that too
where you're just like i don't want to
churn i don't want to read someone's
script a draft of a thing i'm working on
or okay i'm co-writing five different
things we have like the treatments in
the same
okay and we ping-pong it back and forth
then i wait
i'm like okay sometimes i just can't
deal with this because i in terms of
writing
i can only really focus on solving these
problems for the screenplay
so i'll kind of line it up like in a
render queue like okay i'm going to get
through this script
then i'm going to get to that then i'm
going to set it and i schedule it out a
little bit
but i do think that there's a you know
there's
there's the phrase what's the buddhist
phrase chop wood carry water like no
matter who you are
you gotta get up every day it doesn't
matter if you've won the nobel prize it
doesn't matter if you're an oscar winner
it doesn't matter if you're rich but
like you wake up you have to
do the work chop wood and carry water
like you have to and you're no one's
exempt from that and all you're doing is
delaying it and turning it into more of
an issue than it really is
but i think creativity in writing it's
like a muscle you just gotta flex it and
you know look we all get burned out but
i think that setting a schedule and
setting dates
sometimes what i'll do is like if i if
there's a treatment for a project or
a tv thing or a pitch we're going to go
out with i haven't read it i haven't
dealt with it they're waiting on my
notes they're waiting on my rewrite
because
you know so excited about it two weeks
ago and now i'm like oh do i want to
deal with this
i'll set a meeting with everybody then
i'm like oh
[ __ ] this thing is in 12 hours i got to
sit down and do it and then i do it
and afterwards i'm like oh yeah this is
great this is easy this is not
because we look back now you know i was
a freshman in college it was
30 years ago this september and i've
been trying to write every day
from that time you know i graduated film
school to turn writing so for over 25
years now
i can say oh i don't know what like you
know i'm not like an amateur like i
actually know a lot more than i give
myself credit for in terms of
it's just 30 years of just watching
movies breaking down stories and writing
screenplays
so my memory it's like when you're a kid
and you go to some lake and it was so
deep but now as an adult you go in and
it's not that deep at all it's like
your memory of writing is like oh god
this used to take me forever
but now you can actually do it much much
much faster because you've just spent
years doing and you're better at it yeah
well what
what is it though like when you talk to
your therapist like
besides that i mean what you got to be
you're probably really hard on yourself
i mean you are hard on yourself
what is it that you just don't like that
you just go god i wish i could just
do this better why can't i do this why
do i always react this why
i'm impulsive i could um i'm here
i can get irr irritable i can um
you know i could be selfish i could be
you know it's all about me
i could be i can get all those things
and i get really upset with myself
even when i lose my patience i'm like
you know and i'm not a yeller but
you know my dog ninety-eight percent of
the time
i i love him but there's that one time
like what the [ __ ]
yeah and then i'm like why'd you yell at
the dog well maybe because he's deaf and
he can't hear me but
why did you yell at the dog it's like a
default mode like we all have these
default modes
of things that we know works like i i
knew that
i could be like a charging bull to get
something done
and i didn't like that about myself but
i knew if i
went into a room with 10 studio
executives and people that were arguing
against me telling me
it was like a challenge that i knew i
could win the argument
or with like 100 crew members that i
could run it like
through sheer force of will and that
this kind of
attitude that helped when you had no
money and you just had to
charge force on willpower on cabin fever
and at times on hostile
and then just kind of putting myself out
there as making these
ultra violent movies like come at me and
then defending movies like
i had this kind of combative attitude
that i don't think was very healthy i
think by the end of hostile too
you know i found myself getting into a
pattern where i didn't like
that i had to be like that i don't want
to have to i'm not it's not my nature
i'm a pretty
i don't like yelling i'm a pretty nice
person i'm pretty reasonable at seeing
you know people's positions from all
sides and able to and i'm one of my
skills that i didn't good at is i'm able
to really get the best out of people and
get people to do stuff better than they
are
you know kind of believing believing in
them and pushing them in the right way
to like achieve something
great um but that said you know you
i'm like how can i do this without how
do i be a leader without
having to raise my voice without
becoming that guy in the voicemail
director where i start
talking like this and then you know just
going okay i don't like that like how
can i do that
by not being reactive and i think that
you know one of the things that i
that i look at with uh obviously you
know
making movies like our careers are so
beyond our control
but making movies it's like a way of
building a world and controlling that
world because you want to tell the story
and you want the story to go like this
but when you're in this world of chaos
that we're in right now
i mean the world is constantly in chaos
but especially now
i can just there i have two choices i
can sit around and be depressed like why
aren't we shooting
i want to get back to work which is what
everyone's doing or i go what do i need
to learn here
i need to learn that like if there's a
nuclear war if everything ends like i
need to
wake up and be creative and have
something to do and i need to move
forward and i need to
it's just not be like it sucks my
girlfriend's in europe and i can't see
her
and there's nothing there's like nothing
you can do about it um
but we're just like we have two choices
we can be depressed about it we can like
every day going oh this sucks so we can
go hey what are you doing you drawing
you're writing are you creating like
what's you know trying
just get to know each other like just
just go deeper that's right
there is a thing where i felt like i got
credit
for like guilt like like working myself
to the bone
to like not eating not sleeping
living in absolute poverty to like
suffer for
making the movie that i thought that
unless i was under incredible amounts of
stress
and duress and exhaustion and like then
i wasn't going 110
and i realized that a lot of it was that
i didn't know what i was doing or i'm
learning stuff that i
you know couldn't pay people so i was
doing 15 different jobs
and i i thought that like you know it's
like you don't get credit
there's no extra credit for the guilt
like you just have to
that there's a way to be creative and
it's actually when you're kind of
accessing your highest self
and being in that flow when you can kind
of you know it's just a challenge of how
good are you at
tuning out all of these crazy things
that are happening to us and just
staying creative
do you ever go back and go gosh you know
eli in college or
you know eli hanging out at my house on
hill slope that
uh i rented out that had rats in the
ceiling or something do you remember
that right they had rats in the bathroom
and watching uh chowderheads and uh your
show and rotten fruit and
playing guitar there was there was a
little bit of stress
but it was more simplistic it was more
there wasn't this weight on us now
for you is there always a weight on eli
is there always a weight that even when
you feel like you're just
laid back there's still that essence of
gotta do this gotta do that you can can
you chill
it's something that's what i've really
spent the last kind of five years and i
didn't start therapy until about five or
six years ago
because i couldn't and i was like
something's wrong like how can you get
everything you've ever wanted in life
and everything you dreamed of
and still be left this this feeling like
you're under water all the time
like you're constantly letting people
down like you always owe someone a phone
call you like your own notes on the
script like
this person was totally depending on you
for this project because you
overextended yourself and you don't want
to let them down and
don't want to let yourself down and then
you're just like what am i doing why am
i living in this constant state of guilt
until you really just have to you know
you re there's all the other books i
read that
subtle art of not giving a [ __ ] it's a
lot of things yeah i read that for me
it's all about in the ryan holidays
books
but there's uh you know the obstacle is
the way just kind of enjoying the
process
and there was a purity about that time i
will say this like look we've known each
other a long time so that we
we both all kind of migrated out from
new york at the same time
and we met through matt ballard and like
you know we think about there was like a
group of actors
and writers and like we all kind of came
out of film schools like comics
directors actors writers and kind of by
the end of like 88.99 like the kind of
the group the main bulk of the group had
all kind of relocated
you know tom lennon like everybody kind
of moved out west
and i remember you were like a year
ahead of me and i kind of met you and
ballard a whole group of people and we
were all kind of around the same age
we're all like in that you know kind of
mid-20s trying to
make it and and what was great was we
had no expectations there was nothing to
lose like
i remember i remember meeting michael
jan bowling like i have vivid memories
yeah we all bowled and he made this
movie called dairy queens
which was now like they they really i
can't remember the title
the the denise richards beauty pageant
movie but at the time yeah
and i just thought like oh my god like
you got to direct a movie shot on film
with denise richards it was the most
incredible thing
and you had zoey duncan jack and jane
and you were recognizing everywhere i
would say this
you were the most generous like you were
the guy that you know had the most
amount of like success out of any of us
like you had a television show that was
on tv
and a contract and this is pretty
smallville it was like you could afford
to pay for bowling like you could afford
to rent a house like that to me was
like beyond my wildest dreams and doing
chowder heads and doing
rotten fruit like it was sort of being
done for no end it was you're doing it
just to do it like we were just having
fun
like the way we would all go bowling and
it was kind of just cell phones there
were no videos like
barely like the nokia phones like we
weren't
i mean the only evidence that i have is
from my like my film camera when i took
photos from that like you had to bring a
camera somewhere
and shoot the phone you said you just
said no expectations
that to me keeps keeps ringing in my
head that's
when you're when you're early in your
career we're early and we're just
we're excited we don't know what there's
nothing really to lose
there's just you could only go up and so
even when i got on a show i was like
okay but you know this nobody really
knows this show it lasted for
maybe a season and a half but gosh i and
then all of a sudden you
hit something whether it's hostile or
cabin fever or smallville or whatever
and you get to a certain level and all
of a sudden now you have this pressure
why why because you have to be better
than why do you have to be better than
smuggler why do you have to be better
than
hostile where the big thing starts to
make you crazy is that you start to look
at
you know okay what did i want i wanted
horror movies i loved it and then
you get in uh a bigger arena with
hostile and i'm like okay this is
amazing now i have like a legitimate
global hit movie then this acting
opportunity comes up
and i was like i'm going for it i mean
the amount of ridicule i got
of like suddenly being the director of
hustle now going to be in the tarantino
war movie was like
and i was like great i'm going to do
this too and now you have these other
things like do i want to go into this
it's like well not really
that was an amazing experience and i
love acting but i really want to put
like what what do i have time for okay
producing here's rizza has this movie
idea let's
do this kung fu movie and this last
exorcism and
suddenly you look back now and all the
kind of people whose projects
who are involved in your projects that
you helped along the way it's like it's
kind of an amazing
thing but i just feel like i still feel
like i'm just getting going i feel like
you know
i never try to think oh if i'd go back
and do that again i just go okay
i could continue doing this for another
20 years and i'd be splitting myself
into five different ways
now i just want to focus mainly on
directing really but it's taking you
this much time to mature and
mature because what what you start doing
is you start going
you will literally it's just all you're
doing is unlocking happy like when
people go on instagram and they're like
let me just check my likes and then they
they're depressed 15 minutes after
because they either didn't get the
validation they want or the dopamine hit
wore off or someone saw something nasty
and you're like wow i just let it's like
it's like david lynch says your
creativity is this beautiful reservoir
and you're just letting sewage leak into
it when you go and look at that stuff
yeah and it does i'm very good at lying
to myself like oh i'm doing this for
this will be for press this will be like
i gotta do this i gotta you know like
the followers like let me just
it's nonsense it's all like you know
unless that's your job as an influencer
it's not really
for me anyways it just becomes i'm suck
and i go
this isn't making my writing better i'm
actually just using instagram
i don't want to replace the distraction
of many projects
i don't want to like replace that with
social media i was like it's the same
behavior
it's i don't want to get inside my head
so what do i need to do i need to put
down my phone
play some music go for a hike get in my
head
and just sit down and do the pages or
sit down and do the pages then be okay
walking away from it that's the other
thing is that
i've realized that i don't have to sit
in front of a computer for nine hours to
feel like i had a full day if i get
everything done in an hour
i'll put it down think about tomorrow's
scene and then like let it percolate and
that's when other ideas come to you
also there's this weird period when you
have an idea
where you're like so excited about it
you don't care like like i swear to god
like history of horror
was like i don't care if nobody watches
this show
i just want to interview these guys
because toby hooper died you know it's
like
they all died yeah partial gordon lewis
died toby died wes craven died like all
these people i mean
we got so lucky to get to know you know
even like carrie fisher like you think
about the people that to us were these
gods that in our adult lives became like
real friends
i know you were like like i'm i met
carol i wasn't close with her but like
you know wes and toby and these people i
met her school and lewis
i knew all these guys and heartbreaking
that when they go their stories go with
them so i was like you know it's just to
me
whenever i do that like and it's funny
now because the the season two episodes
are coming in and
i'm doing the voiceover from home it's
like there's nothing that gives me a
deeper satisfaction
than watching an episode that's done and
goes this existed
because i kept pushing and we all got
everyone excited about it
and i bothered everybody i like nagged
and enjoyed and begged
everybody to do it and now we have like
this awesome one-hour thing
about you know body horror and killer
kids
and my top 10 weird movies like just
just all that kind of stuff
so i think that the key is you just have
to remember
i i it's like we all have that flow
within us like we we can all
access it and the trick is
really just cutting out your most
insecure parts
to be your biggest self because the
social media like the validation and
stuff it's all fake it's not real
you know the real the only thing that
really matters is sort of what you
push yourself to accomplish i mean and
that's with you with this music
and writing your album and doing your
podcast you're not doing it with the end
game
of if this doesn't become a number one
podcast
i'll be depressed it's like the beauty
is in wow [ __ ] what an amazing
conversation i i like
actually took it took this but we sat
down and we had like a really cool
conversation now we understand each
other
and we're actually going through the
same things it's funny you say that
because i'm listening to it i'm going
there's a lot of truth in what you're
saying mostly truth uh sometimes it's it
it's a little different because
you know when i think of uh instagram i
think you know
and bryce helps me out with this with
social media and stuff but like
you know if i'm gonna play music social
media is the way to go you could tell
your fans you could tell your friends
you could tell everybody
so there's a certain element that it's
it's it's really smart but when
if that's all it is and you're obsessing
did i get this many listeners
look if i was if i wasn't an actor i
don't think i'd be on instagram
if yeah uh if i was getting three
comments
and like eight views why am i
why does anybody care what i'm saying
nobody does so
when you start to influence and you have
you know
hundreds of comments or you know views
and things like that
you know then you could use it as a tool
to spread
uh you know uh i don't know goodwill or
uh yeah i don't think the tool itself
is inherently evil right right i think
that
my use of it becomes narcissistic
sure mine does too don't get me wrong
yeah yeah well and i and i think that
it's it's just about tendencies
and you know some people go on instagram
every day and this doesn't even occur to
them it's not an issue that's not what
they're
and i understand that like you know
kevin hart there's a lot of people that
have built very successful careers
and use social media to like turbo
charge it
for me what is success it was i was
never weirdly i was never focused on
making money i mean i had plenty of
opportunities to do
big movies or much more lucrative things
that i just thought do i want to spend
two years of my life doing this
and i was more interested to kind of go
to chile and see where that led or
go to china i just was like i just want
to see what happens okay let me go on
this adventure
i was more about like it was never
whoever dies
the most toys wins it's like how many
weird cool adventures can i squeeze out
of one lifetime
and tell stories about it and go into
the amazon and go like
i'm sort of an unconventional filmmaker
in that respect
um and it's not that i don't like those
things it's just that that was my
driving motivation was always just more
curiosity to see what else is out there
and
am i what else can i learn and how do i
challenge my expectations for how things
are and
my you know my ideas of other cultures i
want to go there and live there and a
movie was just a great way to go there
and live there and
get over fears and like doing the shark
diving and i'm now
finishing a documentary on shark finning
it's like i think if so many things like
oh yeah i also i'm like almost done with
the movie
you better send me that so i could use
my instagram because uh that's important
exactly where it's good like i mean
sharks are literally keeping oxygen
pumping into the planet i mean they keep
the ocean clean
of all the sick and dead fish and half
our oxygen comes from the phytoplankton
in the ocean and without the sharks and
you're seeing it now they're getting
smothered in algae
because they don't keep the system in
balance and keep away the predators that
should be eating the algae they're not
there anymore so the algae blooms
suffocates the air beings beach is
uninhabitable you can't swim in it
so it's it's like when you see the
moving then what it's for and why we're
killing 100 million sharks a year
it's just it's so i've had this
knowledge for years now it's like it's
infuriating
but that's going to be one where social
media is totally appropriate where
we it's the only way that people are
going to respond to companies absolutely
sponsoring these shark kill tournaments
i just find that like unless i'm
promoting a project and i'll often have
my assistant do it like
i start to go down that rabbit hole
because if you think of it there is that
like 13 year old you know for me there's
that 12 year old fat kid
that no girls liked that you're just
sort of like why
is that why is that person still popping
his head up every now and then wanting
to get
some kind of validation when everyone
was laughing at them going you suck like
there's a part of you that's still there
and you just go you know what
i can't fight it i can't suppress it
just go give it a hug and you go
i don't need it like you acknowledge it
and then you're good isn't that
something
like it's like you have to parent
yourself like that yeah fat kid at the
bar mitzvah
and and i remember i couldn't wear they
said mrs roth your son's not a large
he's a husky
like that and not being able to fit into
a suit getting a fat kid's suit from my
bar mitzvah
was like wow i never thought of myself
you never
that's the thing i don't know what kind
of therapy i'd love to hear someone who
go oh you know what
there look there are obviously a lot of
forms of therapy that could help with
things like that because it's amazing
i've talked about this all the time no
matter how much
somebody will say you're great or they
love you or they love your work or they
did this
and i love it uh they're still
that insecure stressed out
smallest kid in his high school that got
picked on
that no one listened to that felt
completely
there no matter what you do no matter
how big you get
you just have to keep it in check and
you have to talk to it
you have to go you have to say hey this
is when you're young that's not you you
have to sort of like
almost like talk to yourself saying you
can't feel like this look what you've
done
you're not stupid you're not this you
almost have to read it you like talk to
yourself over and over again to get that
title
as like as an adult when you're like oh
you idiot you blew that that was so
stupid why did you do that you're
basically like if you
saw a little kid if a five-year-old kid
came in the room and you went you idiot
why would you do that you're so stupid
like
how would that affect the kid but we're
doing that to ourselves and you have to
think of yourself as a kid in front of
you
going don't worry about it like it
wasn't meant to be
this is it like you grew up man have i
grown like you know instead of beating
yourself up
about the past and your behavior you go
yeah you know what i had some growing i
grew up look how look
you sort of look at it at the
accomplishment of look how much i've
evolved and look how much i've grown
yeah
i feel lucky that we got to live in a
time where a lot of our mistakes were
not recorded you know
oh my god i'd be in prison what
constitutes a mistake now is like what
but also seeing teenagers do some dumb
thing on tick tock one night at their
friend's house
and they say something stupid or
something ignorant and now it's like
they're being kicked out of colleges for
it there's like we won't let you in we
won't let you hear like
that people are actively seeking to ruin
other people's lives before they even
have a chance yeah we didn't experience
that
you know we never had that it was like
you know that culture of
you know you did something wrong like
giving not even helping people
be better or improve or improve their
self but
actually being like let's remove them
from society or not even lambasting
it's such a inhuman practice and it's
also
makes the assumption that they're the
only ones who are doing that
so it's like nobody wants to admit that
like which is human behavior which is
the point of life is you
grow you think you're doing the right
thing sometimes you willingly knowingly
do the wrong
thing think you get away with it or
thinking it's not as bad and you realize
you're kidding yourself or
realizing you hurt people in certain
ways with your own selfish behavior it's
like that's the point of
of growing so i think now i just look at
like
yeah you know what we're coming up on
like like 50 is not that far away
[ __ ] off but you know what i'm good like
i feel like
we've i've i've accomplished a lot i
have a lot left to go
and now i'm really just going to do what
i love and not stress about it but
if you start comparing yourself with the
person who has the bigger house the
person who has more money the person
because that's so rewarded in our
especially in the movie business yeah i
don't care about that anymore i used to
care a little bit and now i
now there's there's something else for
me now i really look you know what
this is weird i i just talked about this
i
can't wait till i'm 55 or 60
because then you could say i could
retire
i don't have to keep doing this if i
don't want to and people won't go what
do you mean you're retired at 48 you're
you're
what are you you're not even a billion
why are you so now i can say
55 i could do it right pension kicks in
at 60. i could take a penalty
and no one could look better oh he
retired he's going to go play golf in
the [ __ ] sarasota
so there's part of me that just like
look will i go crazy my friends seem to
think so you got to keep doing this you
got to be the creative
i don't know man there's almost like
that little kid in me that's just like
hey michael
i just need someone to tell me sometimes
it's okay
you could just do nothing or you could
just do this you don't need to be in the
spotlight
you don't need to make a lot of money
you don't need to live in i have a baby
pool out there i bought it's two feet
deep it's
cost 300 i just needed to take a cold
dip in something because i was hot
right i don't know where that came from
but uh that's all you need to be happy
is what you're saying is that like
sometimes you just go out it's like when
you get to a point
where you're buying things or consuming
things or having things you realize that
what makes you happy is just having a
great dinner with friends you're like
okay
this is this is it i mean i could go you
know you can only sleep in one bed at
night
and often the bigger the house the more
it echoes your loneliness if you're
lonely you know you just start thinking
like what really matters
is being with the people you love and
creating work you care about and also
there was a time when that kind of
adulation was
cool in our eyes because getting
adulation
in the 90s in the 2000s was very hard
like you really
you had to be on a tv show you had to
make a movie
that was the only way you would get that
public adulation now
it's gotten by your phone now you can
get it by doing a funny video
that goes viral and you can get like
that's where the adult
like what used to be impossible to
access
now isn't so it's not special the way it
was to us and
consequently it doesn't matter we
realize how little of that matters like
what really matters is that
you made something that you believed in
and that you cared about that you
thought
no one else could do or the way you
created it the way you did that
character the way it's like
it's there and it's for all time let me
ask you this do you look back and you
think
cause some people will like think
everything they've done is great
i'm not one of those people i will look
back and say wow i could see that was
terrible
that was not good that was you know um
i'm very critical of myself do you do
that or is it hard for you to sort of
like
you know have you ever loved someone and
people hate it or
actually didn't like something that
people really liked
yeah i think that everyone is
self-critical to a degree um i'm
certainly not delusional where you think
it's perfect but
what's so interesting is like i look
back at cabin fever
and i don't think i could have done that
better i know i was thinking
wow that's where my brain was when i was
22. i was 22 when i wrote it and then i
was 28 when i shot it and i was like
yeah this is like a document of my mind
of what it was like in 2001 2002 when i
was shooting it
so when i or 29 30 like
when i watch hostile i go
i just remember that i only had three
hours to shoot that thing we had to
turn it into one shot and that's cool it
worked like
like i'm i'm proud of myself that i went
even green inferno
i go i could have done that better this
scene didn't turn out what i wanted
this this was rush like i should have
given myself more days
but i went to the amazon so that was fun
it was like i made it i wanted to make a
modern
i wanted to make a movie that would make
people talk about cannibal holocaust
that was the course then people in the
italian newspapers were like green
inferno is
such utter trash unlike the masterpiece
cannibal holocaust and i had dinner with
ruggiero de
dado the director and we were laughing
because that same newspaper had called
for his head 40 years earlier
when there's a ripoff like people sort
of go back and they
now the original one is brilliant it's
not right anymore
so i was like i just wanted to make the
movie that people would hate so they
then go and praise your movie i love
that so we were laughing but
you know like like i look at knock knock
and i remember i kind of gave myself a
day for the first like eight pages of
dialogue so i really wanted to focus on
the night scenes and this and i never
got the opening family dynamics and
and so in the edit you're just like kind
of racing through it like what i've
noticed
is that i if you shoot a movie in order
and you're starting with the first scene
you're kind of rusty your crew's getting
to know each other
you get in the groove after a couple
days in the group so like what you
should do is go back and reshoot this uh
you're like oh man
if i had done this now i'm in the zone i
found the characters we got our like
we know kind of the language or the
photography we're using the lighting's
faster
i wish i could go back and reshoot that
so what i try to do now
is i knock knock was the first time i
felt like look i was really proud of the
movie because i felt like after the
jungle i wanted to do
you know more like just a chess match
like like this kind of piece three
people in a house kind of movie
um even though it was very different it
wasn't like a bloody i was like i just
don't want it to show that i can make
make tension with dialogue and how great
was keanu working with
best i love keanu i love working with
him love him
um eli i love it
would you like me to go through the uh
okay great great
um yeah sure okay yeah
that's what we're like we're trying to
show him how to use uh
facetime or like something he's like
okay we're like no keanu you gotta like
okay but how would they see me if the
cameras i'm like no you the camera's
seeing you because it films
he'd never done it that is amazing and
then there's the story in reddit that
was like
keanu reeves gave all his profit money
from matrix to his stunt team and it's
like keanu reeves
gave away 75 million dollars to the
stuff it was the top story and read it
and we're like hey keanu that was so
nice he was like what what what are you
talking about and he's like
we're like yeah you're the top story on
reddit that you gave all your money to
your stun team he's like
what but that's not true i was like i
mean i was nice to them i gave them
gifts but like
and what 75 million like it's like i
gave away 75 million dollars
like what he goes he's like can't we
just call reddit we're like
no it's reddit it's a message board he's
like we'll email them email reddit
tell them tell them that i'm like no
this is great for the movie we're
letting this rumor float
he's like eli you got to email reddit
i'm like keanu the rumor's out there
there's no stopping it like
his his sort of total lack of being
involved in technology
was kind of beautiful and i think that
like so i don't look back and i go
there's always stuff i'm like you know i
could have done that better oh we pulled
that off or that didn't work out as well
but everything's you just go you know
what i'm just gonna do it better on the
next one
like everything and yeah the next one
you're trying ten new things that you
haven't done before it's like okay
now here's the challenge now here's that
now like you know and every movie i
always feel like
i called the roller coaster where it's
just like
when you go to six flags let's go let's
go let's go and the bar comes out go
you're like wait wait [ __ ] this is a bad
idea and you have to look confident
and you're like make it stop it get me
out give it and then it starts going
down the hill and you're like well no
choice now and you're screaming and then
by the end you're like
i want to do that again that was awesome
inside of you is supported by better
help online counseling
i uh these guys have been working with
me a while because
uh obviously people who listen to the
podcast they're getting something from
it
it's uh in these times especially it's
stress
it's anxiety and depression whatever it
is uh
better help online counseling is there
to help they have counselors that
specialize in many areas
relationship conflicts depression like i
said trauma
and it's great because you could
securely connect with your counselor in
a safe and private online environment
and everything you share of course is
confidential we have to know that
all you do is fill out a questionnaire
to help assess your needs and get
matched with a counselor under 48 hours
easily schedule secure videos or phone
sessions with a therapist plus exchange
unlimited messages
my therapist loves me if for any reason
you're unhappy with your counselor you
can request a new one at any time
no charge and you can get professional
help when you want
wherever you want and i'll tell you it's
hearing from me and ryan right here
talking about
just every day there's stress they're
stressed how do you deal with it well
you can't always do it by yourself
so now you can do it and it's uh you
pick up a phone
you know or you get on your computer you
don't have to go to someone's office and
feel like oh my gosh
are people judging me which they're not
the people that the people that are
judging you
are the people that need to be in
therapy more than you
better help is an affordable option and
our listeners get 10 off your first
month with a discount code
inside join over 1 million people taking
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they're recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
get started today at betterhelp.com
inside 10 off from my listeners using
inside
betterhelp.com inside
are you one of those directors that will
because you know i see it i've seen it
where
you know they're doing something and you
can tell it's terrible what they're
doing is not working
and that's human nature and i don't care
who you are spielberg does it
there's a moment where it's not working
and they could put that game
face on like they planned every moment
and they're like yeah let's do this
let's switch this and do you stay
confident or do you kind of
do you are you one of those that could
go hey come here to your dp
let's talk about this how can we make
this better like i'm a little lost but
i need a little guidance do you ever
need like are you uh
humble enough where you could just ask
for advice from people that you you know
you're the director so is that
difficult for you to do um no it's a
pencil you're asking i think that you
always have to have a plan
even if the plan changes like you you've
got to be the leader
like you've got to go in there and go
this is how we're shooting the scene
and my the first thing i like to do is
just go and rehearse with the actors
walk through it so that like as if no
one for no one
but us and quentin taught me that he's
like you know the dp gets his time
everyone they get time to light the
sound guy get their thing the word like
this is my time with the actors i don't
care if the whole crew is standing
around
we're about to do a scene i want to run
it until we're running it like clockwork
so everyone knows where everyone is and
then you run it for the crew and you
want
actually saving time in the day because
everything yeah you can't do that with a
kid you got it like with a kid you have
such limited hours you gotta kind of
okay you're gonna stand here you're
gonna go there
but like you know when you have jack
black and cate blanchett and we're
rehearsing we're walking through and
could you sit here and could i stand
there and like i work it out with them
then i'll bring in my dp and we'll have
a lens we'll just run it guys we just
kind of look while they're performing
the scene
oh we could start in this you know so
you can have an idea like the kill
scenes are like
that's like clockwork like i i got that
figured out by the way do you ever get
intimidated by have you ever
honestly been intimidated by an actor
where you're like it almost made you
feel like a little boy again like you're
like [ __ ] [ __ ] like
i gotta win them back or i gotta they
were you know you upset them
well there's an actor that i worked with
that everyone
legendarily was like this this guy's
tough he's very temperamental
um there were a couple of actors like
that but i just found that if you
approach it from an intelligent place
they knew that i knew movies and that i
knew screenplaying that new character
and that i knew acting
um also almost getting burned to death
in tarantino's movie earned me a lot of
respect with actors
because they're like okay he's not a
post he's not like i'm not some diva
director like
they saw me in glorious bastards they
saw me with the bat they're like okay he
hit the gym
and at the end he was almost like burned
in that fire which we all really were so
they're like okay
he's doing like real [ __ ] in that movie
that i respect so he's not just
at least i approach it as like i'm not
just i know what i'm asking
i understand what i'm asking of you
because i've been in that position
i'm not saying i know better than you
but i'm saying when i'm asking you to do
this
i understand what i'm asking so if they
don't want to
and they're telling me no telling me no
you just gotta like
be you cannot sometimes they're
blustering for other reasons
and you're just like do they not know
the scene have they forgotten something
are they worried about their look like
do they not want their like neck showing
are they worried their arms are flabby
like where is this coming from so i
always try to look at
what's behind me is this a real note are
they really concerned about this
or is there something going on where
they feel like their eyes are puffy and
they don't want me shooting them in
close up
because maybe they had too much wine
last night and then you just gotta let
them know it's gonna be dope it's gonna
be great i got it
look anything digital we're gonna i'm
gonna make sure i got you i get your
back so you never have to worry
digitally by the way
if let's say i show up on set my eyes
are baggy and i'm your lead guy or
whatever and it's a close-up you're
pushing in on a
whatever you know you're really tight on
me and you got big bags and
you just go in there digitally you could
make make them better yeah i mean it's
expensive
you know you have a lot of actors have a
digital makeup pass you know i remember
people came out of summer movie that
started a bunch of women they're like oh
my god they all look amazing they all
look amazing and
you know having done it like everybody
looks bad like how do you maintain a
consistent look like you want your movie
star to look like a movie star so you
have to use this so in
like uh the clock the house with the
clock in the walls i'm sure you went
digitally and make sure everybody looked
because this is a certain feel of
certain look
everybody had to look pretty good yeah i
mean we had a great looking cast
and you know but everybody there's just
certain times
no one looks great all the time no one
looks great all the time even with
makeup it's two o'clock in the morning
two o'clock in the morning
if you've got a long day you're gonna
and you just let them know
there's ways there's companies that i
worked with like this company alchemy
where you shouldn't know that it was
done like we don't want people we don't
want to turn people into marvel cartoon
characters
but there's ways to just like take off
the edges and soften it like if someone
gets a pimple
you can take that out of a shot like
it's gone like it's really like this
actor will be freaking out like
what's this thing right here and you can
paint over it but really
you just sort of in my budget i go and
you and you kind of learn how to
photograph your actors
as you go during the shoot like how this
angle they look better they look better
but also they know that like you're
going to take care of them some actors
have it in their contract
some actors can negotiate that as part
of their deal like what you don't shoot
with me with anything less
than 100 mil no there are actors that in
their contract will have a uh
um what does woody harrelson say 75 i
come alive it's not like he's like
like when he's in close up he's yeah 75
i come alive
but actors will have a digital pass
as part of the thing like okay say
you're trying to negotiate more money
more perks the trailers they're gonna go
no you have to put
an allowance for digital fixes for this
person
so they go through they get to watch it
and they go well there's this scene this
scene in this scene can you please clean
my eyes up
that's debatable you don't want an actor
sitting in there you know
they have to trust you they just have to
be like you you got this right and then
if there's any question you can show
them a shot or two be like
this is how it's going to look right
with it and they go okay great but in
terms of dealing with
uh stars difficulties everybody has
their moments and my job is to look my
dad's a psychiatrist and i was a camp
counselor and a babysitter and that's
your job
is to not get mad i mean sometimes you
have to like when you feel like people
are being lethargic you lead the charge
or it's a difficult thing or there's an
accident or things go wrong
you have to be positive you have to be
upbeat you you set the pace like i'm the
pace car
and if i have energy and i'm focused and
there's a plan and you're respectful of
crew members time
then they'll do it they'll kick ass for
you because they know you're not they're
like
as soon as we get our work done we do it
well and we can go home but
have you ever lost your [ __ ] have you
ever like won of course i mean
you're on set and you're like that's not
what i [ __ ] wanted for the fifth time
i allow myself once a movie once a movie
i'm allowed to lose my [ __ ] does it feel
good kind of
or do you feel bad no because when the
lion roars it's like
i have a very very very loud yeah i mean
the problem that i noticed like on
hostile was
i was so concerned with because i was
young i was like 32 and i was like the
age of the crew members a lot of
criminals are all so
suddenly this american guy is coming and
it wasn't like a 55 year old like tyrant
kind of it was like oh it's eli he's our
buddy
and they started slipping and people
went out like in the middle of the shoot
they were dropping shots because
everyone had a party
people were like out doing coke all
night like the crew members were
and then the next day they were showing
up late they were coming to set in the
wrong costumes the extras weren't ready
and i just lost it and we fired a bunch
of people and i was like this isn't a
party and then i realized it's my fault
for
for letting them think it was like i
shouldn't you know i can be respectful
and i can be nice but i was trying
so hard to be like the cool director
that had
fun with everybody and ultimately
everybody just wants to be really proud
like i realized that
you can have a fun shoot but if you make
a movie
that becomes like a cool movie that's a
hit movie
those crew members are so so proud
to have participated in it especially
hostile which was like an
outside the box weird outside hollywood
movie with mostly foreign actors made
like no one expected it so that like
they had such pride like oh yeah i built
this
i painted those walls i did the torture
chambers we were pumping the blood we
were filming there like they have great
like they got a lot of you know they
they they just had that pride like
that's what people want
those coke addicts they got fired
they're not they don't have a lot of
pride right now they're like
oh god that eli roth [ __ ] fired
you know it's the thing is it's funny
like none of them are bad people
i just think that i i let my guard down
and there were a couple of them that
were letting everyone else feel like it
was okay
and that it's no big deal let's just go
out and have fun
and once you cleared out a couple of
them
everyone else snapped in line there they
got it oh my gosh are we next don't we i
mean look that happened
looking green inferno you know we were
in the jungle and
there was like we had a midway point
there was like a party
in kind of we finished peru we were
going back to santiago and like
i mean crew members went nuts but at
least we were going back to chile with a
new crew
and i just saw you see these side of
people at these kind of wrap parties
midway parties you're like
oh my god why like i've never done coke
in my life after land bias i was like i
was
always scared to be allergic to it
you're an erotic jew like me we don't
want to do that
but it's to me when it's if you want to
do that in your own time do it but when
it starts costing you shots
when the production's affected and
people are being sloppy that's when
you're like okay
all right this is called [ __ ] talking
with eli roth these are questions from
my patrons
spitfire rapid fire i say spitfire can i
not say spitfire
i'll say whatever the [ __ ] i want it's
my podcast [ __ ] taco lee layer off here
we go
ashley g what terrifies you the most the
thought
that i might die without with like too
many
unfinished ideas in my head i thought
you can see like burning alive or
something oh burning life is awful i
mean like yeah i don't
by the way but i don't want to be like
oh acid attack then everyone's like
you know like go with your ideas eli go
with that one thing like
that i die without being able to get all
my ideas out that's that's terrifying
maria m who inspired you to be a
director ridley scott
i watched alien it was a combination of
alien and it was like the combination of
jaws and star wars and the idea
i remember that was the first time i was
conscious of what a director was
where it said produced by david guyler
and walter hill and i said to my dad
who took me i was eight he's like i said
i want to be a producer he said well the
producer has to come up with all the
money it's a directed by ridley scott
it's like what does the director do he
goes well the director gets to spend all
the money and tell everybody what to do
i'm gonna be a director and then i was
aware of george lucas and steven
spielberg but
the first time i read a credit that said
directed by and i want to do that
alien wow of course it was sam raimi
that made it accessible like spielberg
was always like
and lucas were these guys evil dead too
or evil dead right and reading in
fangoria when i was like 13 that sam
raimi was 21 or 20 when he made it i was
like that's not that far away
this is like he made this is what you
can do with 350 000
in a cabin in the woods i didn't really
that's when i was starting to learn the
difference between independent and
studio and 16 millimeter and 35 and
sam raimi making evil dead and that's
why cabin fever i was like i'm gonna get
i'm gonna make a bunch of kids in a
cabin movie and just go out there and
come make a bloody mess and come back
with the footage
hey put me in bruce campbell in one of
your horror movies will you please
by the way i found my casting list for
hostile and it was like
michael rosenbaum unavail smallville you
know what i remember being at the
airport no i remember being at the car
deal like enterprise
and you called me and you were in europe
and uh you're like hey you want to come
do hostile
you called me and asked me and i was
like i'm going i'm doing smallville
and cabin fever i first i i still i told
you about i still regret it to this day
because i love both those movies you
blew up you couldn't move they wouldn't
let you leave they're like we can't dude
they wouldn't let me do anything how was
your moment like that was like suddenly
you're the star of the biggest show on
television that was but still
to do a horror movie a gritty horror
movie with one of your best buds
we also thought i'd be making 30 of
those a year we're like this is easy i'm
going to keep it you know
jesus all right leanne p what new
hobbies have you i
i i heard you just say we will i heard
that leanne p
what new hobbies have you acquired due
to the quarantine rapid fire here we go
jump rope
what jump rope i'm proud you have great
legs i always remember your legs being
really strong and great
thank you mike that's all i want to be
known you're welcome bobby whatever
happened to thanksgiving
white meat dark meat all will be carved
uh
we have it ready the script is done i
have it set up um and it's basically a
timing of coronavirus
and borderlands like i'd like to do
borderlands and do thanksgiving but i
have the script on and we have the
production ready to go
we just uh we actually was we're gonna
shoot it but
i wanted to shoot it now or maybe sneak
it in before borderlands but
corona hit so it's just making it the
problem is thanksgiving is a lower
budget movie you know if you have if
just for people if they're if you're
making a 200 million
movie if you have to add a million and a
half dollars in corona testing
and then if there's a shutdown spend
five million in the shutdown it's not
worth it it's tough things
but on a 10 million dollar movie or
something or 15 like
anything that's under 20 million you
can't like spend a million dollars
testing so
until that gets sorted out a little bit
it's just got a it's ready to go it's
basically packed up and ready to go
chris m i'm gonna answer this question
around what age did you become aware of
your love for horror movies i'm gonna
say eight
eight for sure thank you and was it
something you enjoyed watching with
friends or family growing up
it is you know the i remember when they
came on tv my brothers you know my two
brothers my parents we'd all sit around
and watch
horror movies like when they were
especially when i got we got a vcr when
i was like 11
10 or 11 and we just started ingesting
all of those films
so we might our basement was where we
were allowed to watch anything
because my parents just let all the kids
and my brothers are two years older and
two years younger
so there was always like a couple
friends there's always like a gang of
like nine or ten of us in the basement
which was enough to have like playing
like street hockey sticks like we would
slap shot
tennis balls into my german shepherd's
mouth he was the goalkeeper
what playing like like four square
watching horror movies and hockey in the
basement like that was
that's where we grew up i bet it just
smelled like farts and cheese down there
jennifer c were you able to keep the bat
from inglorious bastards
clinton took the bat there was another
bat like a backup bat that i got but
quentin got the uh the original one
ashley e what's your favorite scary
movie
i don't know it's hard it changes at
times but the one that i go back to over
and over
the shining it's like the shining
exorcist the thing evil dead those
shining exorcists in the like the the
thing people don't give enough credit to
exorcist three
oh joe bob briggs showed it on uh
shutter this year
i love it uh little lisa what scene in a
movie has evoked the most
feelings out of you wow that's a really
good one
um i mean you know it's obviously at
different ages when i was a kid that's
seen in willy wonka when he goes on the
boat and they see all the images and the
chicken with the head being cut off
being slugworth that was like one of the
most amazing
that last battle of pepperland and
yellow submarine
with it's all too much with the stuff
where that mesmerized me
um but really the scene that i just drew
over and over
was like luke and you know the the
lightsaber fight between darth vader and
ben kenobi as a kid like i don't think
i'll ever have that sensation
but really maybe the chest bursting in
alien was yeah maybe the shining the the
door with his face
chopping that door down when she's stuck
in that little bathroom trying to get
her son out
oh i'll never forget that feeling i have
a book like when i was in school when i
was eight years old they gave us a book
where we could color
and so like we could do anything so i
would sit and i would draw star wars
this is like a good look into my brain
and there was just i really wanted to
rewrite star wars like credits
very soon i had coming attractions for
movies
alien rated r i was like okay my
teacher's like what are you drawing i'm
like
i'm drawing a poster for 10. it was two
people in a bed
this is my eight-year-old brain this is
literally what i was doing in school
and they were like look young
frankenstein jaws jaws
this is the most accurate representation
of me as a child
have you shown this book i've like put
the photos out there before
i love that oh yeah look this is another
one this got my parents this like
serious phone calls oh lord is that
puke yes that's her puking all over the
place that's you at eight
this is eight is that raj says is there
a practical effect within your movies
you're particularly proud of
pulling off the leg shaving and cabin
fever we did practically yeah disgusting
the achilles break before we took the
kill bill legs and you reuse them for
hostile and i put a broccoli snap
um but the simple things like in
thanksgiving like the girl impaled on
the cheerleader we just stuck the knife
to the trampoline and had her land and
then just edited them together and it
was the most effective kill but there
was actually
it was actually a trick with editing so
it was literally the most effective kill
and quentin was like that was the
biggest shock in grindhouse at three and
a half hours
that girl landing on the trampoline and
it was nothing we didn't even do
anything
maddie s have any uh events that have
happened in 2020 inspired you
either directly or indirectly in your
writing and
or for future films definitely i mean i
think that
it's interesting because all of my films
are about of you know
a loss of control it's about culture
clash
um and kind of a loss a loss of control
of certain
certain themes that i'm obsessed with
and collect breakdown of society
where i felt like the pandemic started
as cabin fever
and then it like suddenly the like riots
are happening and it's becoming
aftershock
and then everyone's arming up and it's
death wish and
you know it's it's like all of these
things that i've dealt with in the
activism is
green inferno so i feel like all of
these themes that i've touched on
have uh have come up in the pandemic i
hope it doesn't turn into hostile but
all right so look lastly my i have so i
have these horror patrons
and it's called where have all the good
horror movies gone all right because
for me i'm not scared very often
i just nothing really scares me and
there's been some movies that
uh you know it follows the movies that
you talked about
there's been some that really actually
like scary
in recent times i just there's there's
not hereditary was
pretty good uh i just saw the relic the
new one
i liked it it kind of creeped me out
kind of was like the first kind of time
i was felt scared
what is there anything recently in the
last 20 years that actually scares you
like wow this is a scary movie um
or what is it about the lack of really
scary movies like for instance uh and
i'll let you answer
the um the orphanage la orphanage uh
guillermo de toro
when i first saw that i don't know what
happened i i
i was terrified the the hairs on my arms
when they're in the house with the video
cameras i have never been more
frightened
so i'm wondering why is are there so
there's so many horror movies but not
that many really scary movies and
for you what what is it that scares you
and why is it that there aren't a ton of
really scary movies and maybe some that
i haven't seen that you could recommend
well it's hard to be scary you know it's
really hard you got to capture some
essence of something
and do it in this uncanny way the way
that blair witch did in paranormal
activity
where you're watching it happen to real
people and you just feel the sense of
helplessness
and it feels like they're just capturing
what actually happens in little versions
that we've all
kind of felt in our in our life um
the thing is like imagine a cologne that
every time like you perfume like every
time you open it it loses a little bit
of potency like every time you watch a
movie
again the movies the the ride is never
scary the second time through
so the the purity of a horror film is
the circumstances under which you watch
it the first time
matter because that's going to determine
how scary it is if you watch in a dark
room by yourself you're going to get
freaked out
if you're watching it you know with a
bunch of people in the middle of the day
on a phone it's not going to be that
scary
if you go back and watch it again it's
never as scary because you know it's
coming
people are like oh like i always see
these at the end of the decade you'll
see these moronic
top 10 movies of the decades top 10
scariest movies they're always the
movies that are in the last year because
they'll go
you know we went back we re-watched the
ring and it wasn't that scary it's like
there is a great film
the japanese version and gore
verbinski's that is a great movie
and it achieves greatness and it's
terrifying and beautiful and haunting
and
everything about it works the low budget
and the hollywood remake
um but if you watch it again you're
never going to be scared because you
know what happens you know it's
like then you're watching it for other
reasons i think that recently the
films that i watched the one that i
loved the most that got me was trained
to busan
me too that movie i was like in tears by
the end of it
not so scary but just so intense
tension i care so much about these
characters i want
to end like this is this is a nightmare
this is so
this is so good unbelievable i mean it's
also hard to recreate that feeling of
when you're a kid you know when you're
older i know
certain things like you know the ghost
isn't going to be as like
you know when you're a kid and that
stuff's more real like that yeah i mean
hostile really was
tense just tension and it was horrifying
there's no doubt about i walked out of
there going holy [ __ ]
i watch it now and i'm like what was i
like why would i why you know
i know why i did it and i'm not
disowning it because you're [ __ ]
man i had something to prove i was like
this is a nuts movie i was like this is
insane so
um it's fun to do that though it's fun
to push the buttons it's fun to try and
find what's great it's hard though
because i have that same disappointment
you do i'll watch
anything i mean i've been watching i've
been going through like old
80s movies me too movies like evils of
the night and snapshot
there's a lot of stuff i've missed or
never heard of those hold up you're not
looking for them to be
great movies but there's certain movies
that like angel
angel's really good that like that like
remember she was like a honor student by
day
streetwalker by night yeah and it's
beautifully shot by like like andrew
davis
directed the fugitive shot like the
camera works amazing in angel and you're
like they're shooting at all around
hollywood boulevard and
running i was like wow this is this is a
movie that is not just like some
canon movie that i remembered that you
know did you see incident in a ghost
town
no in a ghost land an incident in a
ghost land worst title in history
no i didn't i'll tell you what it's the
guy who directed martyrs oh yeah pascal
i
i know yeah you know ins i actually have
it i actually have it you know what i
liked it i think i think you might like
it i don't i liked it i thought it was
intense
he's a nice he's a nice dude dude i love
you this has been great have you had fun
it's the best such a nice break from
what i'm normally thinking about you're
a great interviewer michael
uh well you're you're great because you
know you have so much insight like i
honestly
sometimes i learn a lot and like the
things that you've said today just about
just work ethic and had it just you know
the psychology of it all and
i think it was very helpful i think a
lot of people are going to yeah i really
i highly recommend stephen king's book
on writing if you get the audio book he
reads it it's pretty fast it's like a
two or three hour read
and it's just it's all about the
creative process and what he does every
day and his routine and it's really like
just makes it kind of
diffuses the mystery and makes it
relatable like when people ask me about
a good book about creative process um
that creativity inc ed catmull's book
but stephen king's book on writing is
really fantastic and it's not you don't
feel like it because he's obviously one
of the best
horror writers in history if not the
best it's not condescending it's easy to
read and
comprehend everyone it's for everyone to
understand yes no i'm saying it's like
not if you're a writer like
just about the creative process and what
he does and stories from childhood and
starting out look at the audio book you
can listen to it on double speed or
speed and a half and be done in like two
or three hours but it really
the principles of just sitting down and
pushing yourself and doing the work and
moving forward and not looking back and
not revising too much
really great dude i love i love this i
love seeing you you really i'm not just
saying this you look fantastic you do
you look really i don't know your whole
either your lighting is spectacular or
you have an aged you really look good
when they see this i
i actually have it in my contract to do
a digital retouch so
oh nice call back you brought it back i
like that lastly i'm going to say this
men's fitness voted you most fit
director in 2006
and all i could think of was who the
[ __ ] was he going against
there is no competition jackson it's
basically like
being you know best dancer to bar
mitzvah
not husky not husky at the bar mitzvah
yeah
but like you're just like well yeah most
fit director it's basically if you can
button your pants
why is that because they're so stressed
all they do is eat craft services
and that's it yeah and actually i've had
fights with the directors about this who
got so mad at me because
on the behind the scenes of the dvds i
was always in shape and they're like
you in that [ __ ] article man i was
doing great as a fat slob
now they look at you and they're like
how come you don't look like him how
come directors aren't supposed to like
you know we grew up they had like the
beard and the parka and they were like
brian to palmer they were like husky
dudes and i was like okay i gotta and
but then i started reading the life
expectancy of directors
someone said it's 57. and i was like
okay i could see that from stress and
eating
and i was like all right i'm going to
make a change i want to be like
just in shape because i want to live and
quentin's theory about directors that
start to lose it because they get
comfortable in the chair they don't want
to get up
they don't want to leave video village
hitchcock director's last movie from a
trailer like
you can't you know it's going to affect
your movies if you just sort of leave it
to the dp and
check the monitor and go back to eating
like if you're up and around and running
you know and you're active you're going
to make a better movie dude if i ever
get him on the podcast he came up to me
at bowling anyone's because [ __ ] lex
luthor
i go you're quitting tarantino i love
him you think he'd ever come on the pod
he doesn't do that does he like he goes
on movie podcasts he likes because he
wants to talk about movie stuff you know
like there's
certain movies like podcast that he was
doing for once upon a time in hollywood
that i was like oh wow quentin went and
did like four hours nerding out with
these guys it's impressive like the
movie well maybe after this air is one
of his best friends
eli you could send it to him and say hey
rosie's a great interview you know i i
will for sure
would you yeah and then i'll be like hey
michael can you start my horror movie
you'll be like sorry i'm in tarantino's
[ __ ] no i'd do anything for you bud you
know that yes man
i love you when this is over we're gonna
hug it out and i just want to hang out
and watch a horror movie with you old
time i gotta like uh
it's all i'm doing writing and watching
movies i love you you're the best
brother
all right see ya
i wanted to talk to him for another
easily another 20 minutes 20 30 minutes
i mean really i just i had so many more
questions i want to
you know pick his brain one of the
things i didn't ask him is like sort of
mentioned it but he does so many things
so i always
you know he says well it's because you
don't want to focus you know put all
your eggs in one basket because then
you're going to be like oh [ __ ] that
didn't work so i have nothing so he's
always spinning plates
now you know you have all these plates
spinning and you're like okay okay this
one this one
but do you think that maybe the quality
of work
diminishes when you have so many
projects because if only one gets going
then you're okay but how do you maybe
it's just me because he's
smarter than i am obviously but uh
i always say that i shouldn't say that
because that's bad therapy i'm i'm smart
but you know how do you i can't uh
what's the word multitask as well
so like if i'm you know to do three
projects at the same time seems like i'm
going to have a heart attack like he
said directors have heart attacks at 57.
maybe that's just how he does it um i
feel like i want to get the best chance
to make that one
project that goes great put all my time
into that so it's the best that it could
be
and not like oh i have a meeting and and
um i don't know how he does it but he's
he's he's
able to do that and um
i commend him for it i do i i i look up
to people who could actually
deal with more pressure and stressful
situations and
um is it possible that maybe i'm just
not meant to be stressed
as much or maybe i stress myself out so
much that
unless i learn how to deal with that
it's just not good
people just operate on different
wavelengths it depends you know some
people are better at just doing
everything all the time and some people
are better at focusing on one thing do
you
get overwhelmed where you uh you could
feel yourself going what do you do what
show me like your body movement and your
your sort of physiological
uh like what happens to you when you
feel like you're getting like that
uh i mean it just feels very i don't
know it just feels like really tense in
here it sort of feels like your heart's
being like just like wrung out
like it like a towel i don't know if
like does it scare you
yeah and how often does it happen i mean
these days all the time
because you know it's just you it's you
it's hard to find any solace in the
regular world because the regular world
i mean i'm here i'm wearing a mask
cause that's just what it is so it's
hard not to be stressed all the time
uh i mean i don't know like i think
they're if i need a moment
i will i will literally i'll i'll grab
one of my guitars and i'll just go lie
on my bed like and stare at the ceiling
and just noodle
and that's and and that if i can find a
moment to do that i'll do that for
half an hour see you're using those but
sometimes
but sometimes when i'm like really deep
into it i just want to like go
deeper into it and just like keep
working and keep working and i just
won't find the time to
to not stress out right your mask is
stressing me out because your nose is
showing
it's small because you know you have
headphones on you know it's over the
wire now
i think did you wash it mistake you got
to hand wash those things
really i've seen so many runners just
like with the mask just below the nose
that's how it works bro i've said things
to some i went to a restaurant just get
uh
take out and her nose is showing and i
actually almost turned around and left
and she's like i can help you and i go
uh cover your nose please i was nice
about it
oh i'm sorry and i'm like yeah i'm sorry
i just don't touch my food
by the way again the birthday messages
the uh the messages on twitter
i thought you know i man so supportive
and by the way how cool is that pill
leah stubbs and kristen they made that
for me
uh it's just incredible look at that all
the names embroidered of all the guests
ugh i'm gonna fall asleep on that and
salivate and the pillows
i mean come on with my face on it are
you farting on my pillow over there
all the time all right here are the
shout outs to the patreons uh
real big uh lastly um thank you to my
good friend al goff
creator of smallville who listens to
every podcast um
dane cook who's a big supporter of the
podcast um
all my friends out there um julie benz
uh i mean a lot there's a lot of people
that i'm
naming celebrities that list in the
podcast sean gunn and chris
sullivan and you know it's nice when you
get messages saying hey man i really
liked your podcast because look it's one
thing of course to
you know your fans your friends your
listeners your family but when your
peers also
like it it just the [ __ ] it makes you
feel good man i like it so hey if you
want to join patreon inside of you
support the podcast more if you like a
lot of fun goodies there and prizes
i'll be doing an instagram live this
week um
what else uh and then me and john heater
with the
where have all the good horror movies
gone patreon exclusive go to patreon and
uh
zoom with us and have fun it's a fun
little horror club
uh you got anything going on do you need
anybody to know about their uh
ryan not at the moment all right um
july 30th in forma i will do a virtual
con with tom welling
we're going to do zooms and all that
stuff it's the it's soon
but soon it's like in two days here on
my patrons i just want to give a shout
out to nancy d mary b
leah s trisha app sarah v little lisa
yukiko
jill e brian h lauren g nico p barry i
angel i love reading these names i
always say that but i do angelina g lee
uh robin s cherry w kevin r emily k
bobby
robert b jason w steven j kristen k
amelia d
allison l tom n jess j
lucas m raj joshua d emily s
we're getting more and more man people
are really joining this patreon tier of
the top tier there and
support and it's unbelievable like holy
[ __ ] man oh hopefully i can quit my job
someday and just be a patron just do
patreon just hanging out with all these
folks i can't wait to throw a big party
cjp samantha m humza b
it's funny because i just sent a lot of
these people uh mugs there's autographed
mugs that you can get online
we just ran out but i ordered more and
uh masks and shirts and all sorts of
[ __ ]
hamza b jennifer n stacy uh beth carly t
reim jennifer s janelle b tabitha c
kimberly e melissa c mike e jake m
marissa and judith d ramirez
beth b chris f sarah f chad w leanne p
hi jackie p rodrigo s rodrigo
rachel c rey a maya p megan d jennifer c
moddy maddie s hi sorry maddie tiffany i
i think it's tiffany i it's got to be an
i always it would be an l
it's tiffany i right it's a straight
line yes
tiffany hi hi tiffany i i missed your
name up last time kendrick f
ashley e margie m
sigourney p tom t matt w belinda n
benjamin r lisa j kevin v robert s
and joy pump it up pump it up in pain
joy w thank you guys for listening
uh support uh charities help people out
we've got
uh foodonfoot.org am i wearing that
hat right food on foot dot org i'm
hosting a thing for uh food on foot
uh to try and help raise money so it's
great uh it helps homeless people and
like no other organization does for
homeless people it's unbelievable
and many of you have donated and i get
these calls saying
another one of your uh listeners from
the podcast or patrons
donated rob calls me and goes donated to
food on foot i'm like are you kidding me
they already give so much i i just [ __ ]
so nice and sorry about the f-bombs i
usually don't f-bomb this much but i'm
f-bombing
um also of course ronald mcdonald house
of los angeles
love my folks another shout out to my
buddy who i met at the ronald mcdonald
house
preston christensen i love him
so for his birthday i got him so we're
big jim crotche fans he's 14. he just
turned 14 and i turned 48 three days
later
um i got him a turntable
an old jim crotchy album sealed like an
old
album and a jim crotchy shirt so he
and his mom sent me some videos of them
and i just love that kid he's a good kid
and then i called um
the radio station lisa fox here in l.a
and she said
this goes out to uh preston christensen
and he's like what it was so cool man
i actually cried i listened to it on the
radio alone i was like
it's so sweet such an idiot
but uh and echoes of hope of course
thank you guys so much i hope you
enjoyed eli roth i did i think it was
great
spread the word man it's up to you guys
it really is spread the word
subscribe do what you got to do help me
help you i love you
and uh ryan you love them i love them
too
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of each
and every one of you
you